on est en direct non touche pas mon
poste et ce soir nous sommes avec nos
amis je dis bien nos amis agriculteurs
qu'il faut absolument soutenir euh je le
dis à tous ceux qui nous regarde ce soir
en direct euh plus vous soutiendrez les
agriculteurs plus le gouvernement fera
les choses vite et fera bouger les
choses rapidement vous savez comment ça
se passe hein voilà donc allez-y
soutenez nos agriculteurs et n'hésitez
pas même à les aider au quotidien parce
qu'on en a besoin nos agriculteurs parce
que euh vous rendez compte le nombre
d'agriculteurs qui baisse de d'année en
année hein c'est c'est c'est fou alors
que c' un métier c'était le métier du du
rêve agriculteur 100000 fermes ont
disparu en 10 an donc ah ouis donc je
vous dis donc voilà et aujourd'hui je
suis très heureux de recevoir Patrick
Philippe et et Stéphane et il y a Pascal
qui est dans le qui est dans le public
aussi qui qui va nous faire part de de
de de son expérience que c'est important
qu'on ait beaucoup de témoignages pour
que vous voyez bien la situation parce
que comme j'en parlais avec Stéphanie un
instant c'est vrai que les généralités
c'est important mais pour les Français
qui nous regardent ce soir ils ont
besoin de voir quelle est votre
situation et de s'identifier à vous et
de se dire moi Stéphan on en parlait il
y a un instant on a toujours dit euh
quand on était petit on nous a dit si tu
travailles bien et si tu travailles
c'est tu un travail tu vas t'en sortir
tu vas tu vas voilà il faut que tu
travailles pour t'en sortir et pour
pouvoir faire ce que tu veux dans la vie
pouvoir manger et pouvoir faire voilà
avoir des enfants et pouvoir les nourrir
et aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
métiers et et les agriculteurs
particulièrement et ben ils peuvent pas
s'en sortir aujourd'hui et et c'est vrai
que le problème il est ça fait 2 ans
qu'on parle des agriculteurs ici hein ça
fait 2 ans qu'on dit qu'il y a une
urgence et pour moi il y a rien qui a
été fait j'ai pas vu d'amélioration
c'est juste qu'un moment on met les
problèmes sous le tapis et on se dit bon
bah de toute façon ils vont oublier les
agriculteurs ça y est on les a vu sur
trois quatre plateaux télé ça y est on
en a parlé ils ont fait deux trois
action terminé c'est bon bon les
agriculteurs on les entend plus bon B
c'est bon donc on laisse tomber
reviendront dans 2 ans on va passer à
autre chose donc c'est vrai que là je
vous le dis il faut vraiment euh bien
sûr ne ne pas lâcher l'affaire et il
faut vraiment que vous ayez gain de
cause parce que sinon ça va être encore
2 ans et 2 ans et 2 ans et 2 ans et euh
un moment on pouveit plus attendre là il
y il y a une urgence euh Stéphane vous
vous êtes très très endetté
oui voilà ouais vous avez beaucoup de
mal à sortir la tête de l'eau je sais le
moral il garde le moral Stéphane et
c'est oui oui on a pas le choix et puis
on est là aussi pour transmettre du
courage pour garder le moral agriculur
depuis 2015 est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter votre situation j'ai envie que
les Français qui nous regardent ce soir
comprennent votre situation pourquoi
endêter tout simplement bah déjà là au
moment de la reprise de l'exploitation
de mes parents pour ma part je me suis
installé avec ma femme qui est ici prè
présente dans le
publicembrasse on a
forcément dû donc racheter l'entreprise
déjà de nos parents donc forcément ça a
un certain coup déjà pour commencer
ouais ensuite on a développé développé
nos vente dans un tout premier temps on
était en vente direct mais on avait
beaucoup de demandes beaucoup de
demandes de tout horizon que ce soit du
semig gros donc du magasin du
grossistein je peux parler sur R ou tout
ce qui est mine mais aussi en industrie
donc on avait vraiment de la demande sur
tout types de production on est axé sur
la production légumière et aussi un
petit peu céréales mais c'est notre
métier c'est vraiment le légume et par
en 2020 depuis depuis octobre 2020 vous
avez dû jeter une grosse partie de votre
production ben voilà c'est ça tout s'est
retourné bon al au moment du covid ça a
vraiment été un effet boule de neige le
covid ça s'est suivi par
l'inflation en fait bon nous on était
quand même axé aussi beaucoup sur la
restauration collective pendant le le
covid d'un seul coup tout s'est arrêté
forcément les gens ont beaucoup fait de
télétravail on arrêté de bah de bouger
voilà on consommait de manière
différente et nous d'un seul coup voilà
même avec des contrats même avec tout ce
qu'on voulait on nous a dit bah la
marchandise ça sert à rien de nous
l'expédier sauf qu'il faut bien savoir
qu'entre 2015 et 2020 dans un cas comme
le nôtre et ben on a beaucoup on a
beaucoup investi pourquoi beaucoup
investi ça peut être ça peut être
contredit aussi sauf que voilà je vais
parler d'un d'un très gros
investissement chez nous c'est
l'irrigation ouais voilà qui est
controversé aujourd'hui oui et non sauf
que sans les sans irrigation sans eau je
sais pas dans quel ét on finit nous-même
sans eau un légume c'est pareil c'est
impossible quoi bien sûr voilà vous
souffrez beaucoup de la hase des prix de
l'électricité aussi ah chez nous c'est x
10 c'est affreux c'est ça ça ça il faut
mec vous rendez compte x 10 mais comment
tu fais et ben ben on est cerné on est
cerné on est écrasé qu'est-ce que tu
faisas l'électricité qui qui est
multiplié par 10 quand tu comment
comment tu comment tu veux t'en sortir
en
vérité impossible dans notre cas bah les
terres faut les travailler on utilise
des tracteurs un tracteur il y a pas ça
consomme on pe pas faire comment le
temps des chevaux est terminé peut-être
qu'on y reviendra mais avec comment tu
te nourris Stéphan tu te nourris de tes
propres productions entre autres ah oui
ça c'est je peut pas c'est impossible
d'y
échapper impossible d'échapper mais
c'est pour ça bah ouais mais les mecs
ils se rendent pas compte je ils se
rendent pas compte à un moment il faut
faire au cas par cas un moment tu dois
dire les agriculteurs il faut trouver
une solution pour les agriculteurs même
sur l'électricité je suis désolé il y a
il y a des solutions à trouver et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y a des
efforts à faire par déjà dans la grande
distribution comme on l'a dit il y a des
efforts à faire au niveau de
l'électricité et que les mecs se gavent
et que derrière lui il paye x 10
électricité comment tu veux qu'il s'en
sorte non mais c'est je vous dis quand
quand vous nous expliquez les choses et
je suis sûr que les Français et les gens
qui nous regardent ce soir en direct
doivent se dire franchement comme une
fois de plus on marche sur la tête c'est
on se rend pas compte en fait et et et
on on trace on est on fait tous notre
vie et on se retourne pas un moment à un
moment on va se retourner on va on aura
plus d'agriculteur on aura à l'heure
actuelle moi j'ai la chance d'avoir ma
famille et puis euh voilà on est on est
soudé mais faut bien savoir par des
autres tu disais moi mon cas il est pas
isolé moi je ma chamb mais voilà Pascal
qui est avec nous dans le public bonsoir
Pascal merci d'être là bonsoir merci
tuas pas besoin d'enlever les lunettes
qui t'avais reconnu merci Pascal merci
d'être là Pascal raconte-nous un peu ton
histoire toi aussi tu agriculteur parce
que voilà vous êtes venu à 4 ce soir je
voulais vraiment qu' qu'il ait pas mal
d'agriculteur qui parle c'est important
oui j'étais pas forcément venu pour
raconter mon histoire je suis
agriculteur à G ENF l'garon dans le 47
mon fils derrière moi prend la suite il
est la 7e génération à exploiter la
propriété et c'est de plus en plus
difficile alors ils vous ont tous
expliqué hein que ce soit les trois
agriculteurs qui qui qui ont parlé ce
soir on va pas parler des normes de la
concurrence déloyale de la concurrence
sociale com vous voyez dans les autres
pays où euh ils embauchent de la maain
d'œuvre à 3 € de l'heure qui arrivve
d'Afrique comment vous pouvez faire face
à ça bien sû donc ce soir j'ai juste un
coup de gueule à passer euh Agen lchera
pas ils ont ils ont encore mon fil
j'étais encore ce matin là-bas dans les
sur les barrages
euh ils annoncent des autres des hausses
de d'électricité c'était pas le moment
quoi ils annoncent de une une une
surtaxe du GNR en accord avec la f
c'était pas le moment pas du tout il y a
il y a beaucoup de choses à enlever même
la taxe foncière il y a beaucoup de
choses à enlever la Agen on lachera pas
je pense que les autres nonont plus je
pense que le mouvement va se déplacer
sur Bordeaux si jamais ça continue voilà
c'est tout la peur que j'ai c'est que
bon il y a eu un drame à Pamier ce matin
c'est quand on voit l'état de la voiture
il y a quand même c'est quand même
bizarre quoi mais
on lâchera pas et et et je sais que que
le gouvernement joue avec le temps ou
mais le savent ils vont s'épuiser c'est
ce que je vous ai dit dans un instant ce
que je vous ai dit un instant ou exa et
et bon et la crainte que j'ai c'est
qu'après nous avons les forces de
l'ordre et là ça va mal finir merci
Pascal merci Pascal merci Pascalou voule
il voulait nous parler aussi Pascal ce
soir merci à vous d'avoir été avec nous
est-ce que vous avez un dernier mot à
dire je crois que vous aviez un dernier
mot à dire oui si vous voulez que la
situation s'améliore faut sortir de ce
mécanisme des traités de libre échange
faut revenir sur la coopération entre
les États et il faut
encadrer la transformation les
industriels et la grande distribution
parce que nous on vend à des industriels
on vend pas à Michel Douard Lecler on
vend à des industriels et vous savez
pourquoi les agriculteurs vont
manifester sur les routes dans les
préfecture dans la grande distribution
mais qui vont jamais manifester chez les
industriels ou très peu parce que les
industriels ils tiennent les
agriculteurs voir il les finanent à
travers les coopératives donc c'est
difficile d'aller
manifester chez quelqu'un à qui on doit
de l'argent et en plus il est en
cogestion avec le syndicat parce que le
syndicat c'est l'industrie
agro-alimentaire c'estàd que chez nous
en agriculture on a une particularité
c'est que Arnaud Rousseau ou ses
successeurs madame Lambert nous le
président du syndicat dit majoritaire
25,8 % des paysans qui représent quand
même faut que je le pré
nous notre président FNSEA il est en
même temps secrétaire comme si que
Philippe Martinez avait été en même
temps vice-président de Renault pougot
et Michelin pas possible il y a conflit
d'intérêt Patrick voulait rajouter
quelque chose non mais pour finir moi je
pense que aujourd'hui c'est tellement
grave que c'est plus un problème
syndical je pense qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on avait des convictions
comme vous je vous vois débattre vous
avez des convictions mais devant le
drame qui a eu lieu le drame des
agriculteurs qui peut arriver et le
drame aujourd'hui on va dire financier
comme j'ai dit aujourd'hui urgemment si
on est un président ou on un premier
ministre il y a des il y a des sommes
qui n'ont pas été payées depuis le mois
d'octobre vous imaginez les mecs ils ont
pas été payés depuis le mois d'octobre
200 à 300 millions d'euros pour un pays
la flamme olympique puisque on m'a
demandé la flamme olympique pour qu'elle
soit transportée jusqu'à Paris ça a
coûté 18 millions d'euros faut
relativiser tout donc moi j'ai rien
contre la flamme olympique j'ai rien
contre le fait qu'on donne 40 millions
de plus à Madame Holland à Madame
Hollande
à MAD
pour le système des jeux olympiqu je
suis content mais merde on ne pay pas
depuis octob priorités gars pour payer
tous les jours ici Pat je te dis a des
priorités je je pas parler d'autes
problèm on va pas parler d'autres
problèm parce que l'argent il est
débloqué sur
voilà
même Gest là si le gouvernement ne peut
pas donner ça tout de
suite demain à Bruxelles parce que on va
voir on nous dit que Bruxelles commande
et on va justement voir si c'est
Bruxelles ou c'est en FR ex par qu'on
nous dit toujours c'est Bruxelles he ça
c'est truc on mais c'est pas c'est
Bruxelles c'est pas nous merci on peut
quand même dire qu'on est un pays qui
marche sur la tête on est quand même une
puissance mondiale et on fait crever on
fait crever les gens qui nourrissent la
population c'est-à-dire les paysans Parà
ma connaissance ici tout le monde mange
donc nous on nourrit la
population suicid par jour quand même
n'oublz Jama merci à vous qu d'avoir été
là merci à d'avoir été là également
merci beaucoup c'était vous reviendrez
quand vous
voudrez il a d payer des droits de
succession pour récupérer la ferme de
ses parents ou on enarlera merci c'est
un trucou maisme ça on devrait
l'enever non mais je vous dis il y a
tout à revoir donc forcément dès que tu
mets le doigt sur un problème tu tires
il y a problèmes qui arrivent donc c'est
n'importe quoi merci non merci j tu as
raison de le dire ça aussi déjà c'est
premier truc à faire mec n'importe quoi
merci l'erreur pour les pour les
agriculteurs ouaisouis merci merci merci
tu tu parleras demain là parle à Gill
euh merci r merci en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous merci beaucoup c'est N qui
vous remci merci beaucoup et vousz
vousou